la conclusion c'est que les 32 articles
qui font l'objet d'une censure au titre
de cavaliers n'ont pas été jugés sur le
fond donc ils n'ont pas été remis en
cause sur le fond et pour cause
puisqu'on a traité que la procédure et
que la forme donc je pense qu'il est
important que le gouvernement qui par
ailleurs pourquoi le Conseil
constitutionnel ça veut dire qu'il
aurait décidé de ne se se s'en tenir à
la il a considéré que il fallait s'en
tenir exclusivement au textes d'origine
déposés par le gouvernement qu'on ne
pouvait pas aller au-delà de ce qui Ava
été déposé par le gouvernement et là il
décide par un moyen de procédure
d'écarter tant deux articles il en a le
droit avec une interprétation très
stricte de l'article 45 et de ce fait ne
les juge pas sur le fond alors ce qui
est intéressant aujourd'hui une fois
qu'on a constaté tout cela c'est que le
gouvernement qui pendant les débats qui
pendant les débats par l'intermédiaire
de son ministre avait soutenu la
majorité de ces amendements il suffit de
revoir les débats et on verra très vite
que l'amendement déposé par le Sénat a
été adopté a été a été soit avis
favorable ça n'a pas été remis en cause
par le gouvernement après un vote en
commission je suis un peu technique mais
c'est ça bah devrait immédiatement
redéposer un texte sur la base de ces
amendements qu'il avait souhaité qui par
ailleurs ont fait l'objet d'un accord en
commission mix
paritaire